سابقه في تاريخ امريكا للمره الاولى رئيس
امريكي سابق يواجه تهما جنائيه في بلده
خلف هذه الابواب سيتقرر مستقبل تشومب
السياسي وبالرغم من ان بيان الادانه لم
يصدر بعد الا ان صداه باح باهم اسراره
يواجه قضيه ظن سبع سنوات مرت انه قد دفنها
دون عوده قبل ان تحيها شهاده محاميه مايكل
كوهين وقف في الجهه المقابله هذه المره
واعترف شخصيا بدفع ثمن صمت ممثله الاباحيه
130 الف دولار من اموال حمله ترومبا
الانتخابيه
سيمثل امام القضاء الطواعيه هذا الثلاثاء
كما صرح محاموه لكن ما يبدو تعاونا قد
يحمل تهديدا للديمقراطيه الامريكيه لا يقل
عن احداث الكابيتول وتحسبا للجوء انصار
الترومب لخلق الفوضى فتحت المحكمه باب
التفاوض لتامين مثوله الامن لكن ماذا ان
غير تشومب رايه وقرر البقاء في بيته في
هذه الحاله قد يكون مثوله امام العداله
ارحم من بقائه في فلوريدا القانون
الامريكي يتيح الصلاحيه لحاكم الولايات
باعتقال المطلوبين وتسليمهم لولايه اخرى
معقل للجمهوريين لكن حاكمها رونالدو يعد
اشد خصومه ولن يضيع فرصه التخلص من ترامب
على النقيض حكم الديمقراطيين لنيويورك خد
هذه المره الولايه اقرت قانونا لا يسجن
المتهمين في القضايا التي لا ترتبط باعمال
عنف القانون الفيدرالي بدوره لن يقف امام
الطموحات الترومب السياسيه حتى في حال
ادانته يبدو واثقا وبدا حملته الانتخابيه
تحت الاضواء وقبل الجميع لعبه دور الضحيه
وحد الجمهوريين وراءه في الوقت الذي تبدو
الحدود بين الترامب المترشح والمتهم
ضبابيه